The way that you build a portfolio, or
buy stocks that you hold in your
portfolio, is by issuing orders.
Usually you send those orders
to a stock broker, and
they take care of executing them for
you.
We're going to dive now into
the details of what happens
when you create an order, and
how it gets to the market and back.
And how things can go wrong, and
how they can potentially go right.
The first stop there is to think
about what is actually in an order.
What are the components of an order
that can go to a stock exchange?
Here is all the information that
must go into a well-formed order.
First of all,
I need to know are you looking to buy or
sell shares of a stock?
Next is the symbol.
This is an identifier for the stock or
perhaps ETF that you want to buy or
sell, for instance IBM or SPLV.
Next you need to tell your broker how
many shares you want to buy or sell.
Stocks and ETFs and
other assets are sold in units of
shares, not by amount of money.
So you don't tell your broker I
want $100,000 worth of Apple,
you tell your broker I want
a thousand shares of Apple.
Next, you need to tell your broker
whether this is a limit order or
a market order.
Let's start with market first,
market means you're willing to accept
a good price but essentially whatever
price the market is currently bearing.
And I'll show you in a moment
how that's determined.
A limit price means you don't want to
do any worse than a certain price.
For instance,
suppose you're selling some stock.
You might specify I don't want it to
be sold below a particular price.
Or if you're buying stock,
you might say, I don't want to pay
more than a certain amount to get it.
If you're issuing a limit order,
then you have to say what
the corresponding price is.
If it's a market order,
you're not able to specify that price
because essentially when you issue
the market order you're saying I'll
take whatever price comes back.
Let's take a look at
a couple example orders.
Here's one.
Buy IBM, 100 shares, limit, 99.95.
So this means I want to buy 100
shares of IBM at no more than $99.95.
Another example, sell Google,
150 shares, market.
Notice there's no price
with this because
we're going to take whatever
the market price is.
So let's look at what happens when
these orders reach the exchange.